Rick is in Danville Illinois hi Rick
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show they
gave how you doing I'm hoping maybe I
can get from six aspirins down the to a
day after talking with you oh I'm I am a
house husband my wife and I we've been
together now I'm married for 15 years we
have six children 15 to 3 years old she
works now field that has a lot of
opportunities for advancement uh was
just a couple of years of schooling at
all we have two homes our biggest
problem is is that um or my wife likes
to just do this stupid spending you know
I've told her that you know I've been
listening to you now for the last few
months and all that what is stupid
spending I'd like you to go to Walmart
and instead of like doing some food by
her boobs of some food mind she'll buy
like you know now they're coming out
with these new figurines for x-men and
stuff like that it costs forty nine
dollars for six of them your wife likes
x-men figurine now first show so get
them for our one son we have boys two
girls okay and then it's like well this
top was only seven dollars or this was
only this or this was only that and it
just driving me utterly crazy so you
guys aren't living on a budget i when it
comes to her doing the shop you know I
mean you know we need to get on we need
to get on a written plan that the two of
you agree to each month and if buying
figurines or toys for the kids or
however we want to categorize that is
within that budget then she needs to be
able to buy that and you need to shut up
but we need to be on a written plan that
we're both in agreement on the category
amounts before the month begins I'll
give you an example my wife Sharon has a
healthy clothing budget it's just the
two of us now when we do well so she can
spend a lot and that's fine I have no
trouble with that at all
and she's not a big spender but uh she
buys some things that I would never buy
but I don't care because it's it's she's
living within the amount that we both
agreed to
and so if she wants to spend that on a
purse I would I wouldn't do that but
that's fine if that's what she wants and
it's within the amount we were trying to
do what I'm trying to do is like with my
little bit of a side job which I call
anchoring and that's like you know
buying something and exulted for profit
whether it be it it's um
auctions or something like that and
believe me I don't go to every single
watch and I mean it you know it's just
here and there that's fine too as long
as you do it within a budget the deal is
you guys are not in agreement you're
going over there and doing that she's
griping about that you're she's going
over here and buying figurines your
griping about that because you guys
don't have a plan that you're in
agreement on you need to sit down and
have a written budget before the month
begins every dollar has an assignment by
category and some categories are her
spending in some categories or your
auction thing you're doing and that's
all fine there's nothing wrong with that
as long as we're doing it on paper and
we're both in agreement and we don't go
over that and so we both are in
agreement I have an amount I spend and I
don't have to report back to Sharon on
that category you could have an auction
category she can have a figurine
category or it could be toys or it could
be a Walmart miscellaneous wasted money
category I don't care what you call it
as long as you're in agreement and then
that gives that person the freedom to
have a little bit of a life within this
spending plan that we're both in
agreement on but but let me just tell
you neither one of those things are
killing you guys what's killing you is
other stuff probably in your budget and
the fact that you're not doing a written
plan but all this conflict in your
relationship is because you're not in
agreement be in agreement before the
money leaves don't gripe about it after
it's gone and stay within the guidelines
that we both agreed to and so if you get
it an auction and something's going low
and you're you're pasture auction budget
Tuffy's you can't buy it because the
amount allocated that you guys agreed to
you have to stay within if she goes to
Walmart and the figurines are on sale
and she's used up her figurine or her
Walmart budget and she doesn't have any
extra money
Tuffy's she has to say no because we're
not an agreement passed a sir
amount of money you've got to give
yourself guardrails boundaries and say
this is out-of-bounds this is how we
this is what falling off the road looks
like this is what running in the ditch
looks like this is what going over the
line and being out of bounds and a
whistle is blown looks like the problem
is is that you know she's calling your
activity stupid and you're calling her
activities stupid and it's possible that
both of them are but really none that
really matters what matters is you're
just not an agreement and if you'll get
an agreement then the conflict will stop
before the spending occurs by category
every dollar of the manual of the
monthly household income has a name as
an assignment has a mission assigned to
it on paper on purpose we look at that
we even initial it as a contract we
pinkie swear we spit shake this is who
we are this is what we're doing we're
not doing anything else with money if I
do something else with money it's the
same as me lying to you because I've
just given my word I've just locked this
down and when you do that everybody's
free then and Sharon can go spend money
on clothes and I don't have to go what
you spend on that that was stupid
why'd you do that and I don't have those
conversations at my house for 20 years I
haven't had those conversations it's
freeing it's awesome so give it a
written gameplan set yourself free this
is the Dave Ramsey show
you